[Musique]
ça va ça va ça va c'est pas un truc de
ouf il est vivant on plaît j'ai lu ça va
quand même le nez cassé et monsieur
quand s'ouvre par le net à siffler c'est
super je loue et je peux écrire des
mélodies à ça fait mal aussi
c'est du sport dans tous les sports et à
des blessures pouvait pas faire du sport
normal de temps en temps comme tout le
monde voulait quoi que je fasse du ping
pong comme dans tous les collèges c'est
ça ouais une activité de mer dont on va
se faire chier avait arrêté accès
gremaud redouane c'est pas possible à
l'école ici c'est bon j'ai compris
on va faire du ping pong bombe au tac
tac tac ping-pong sport d'enculés web ni
que sa mère le ping pong
[Musique]
arrête de boîte et s'est tournée qui est
cassé bon là et là on en est à combien
de partout la ola la balle de match on
se départagent sur les excuses moi ouais
je sais mais ton parachute du louvre
avant ou après ton corps de matt levitt
face à la tente un petit super gardien
crois tu que ton la vaisselle en cours
c'est peut-être pourquoi m'ont pas mal
et sinon donatello au ton frère michel
angelo et vient plus à l'école et y
aller je vais porter un lapin franquin
court court court mais s'il te plaît
enlève ta carapace avant de rentrer en
cours et aux deux cas rigoler 3 2 je
gagne c'est mon dieu désolé si j'ai pas
entendu moore est né ouais mais je
comprends tu vert du 13e c'est loin
trois noms qu'on pense à moi mon choix
sera combattue rice a fait 3-3 je
voulais lui demander si celui qui avait
fabriqué mes pompes mais si on se cale
ça suffit
être agent technique est et claquettes
ou sans vous êtes un troisième c'est une
année très importante pour vous mais
pour ça il y à quelques règles à
respecter
je leur donne aucune limite tu crois que
tu leur en service on les gère tous les
états d'accorder enfin un concours alors
attends quand on aime se fout
ouvertement de ta gueule qui dicte que
physiquement tu ressembles office de
trump croisé avec bang non pour moi
c'est de l'irrespect du mont franchement
sur la vie de mark mais peut-être
comment go je le sais tu as la tête
avant donne était devant genk de van
gogh excusé de sa prof de maths quand un
prof du ps tu pèses plus de 100 kg soit
c'est de la merde en vaut bien un parent
que vous
allez ciao double vie de ma mère la même
tête que van gogh ce phénomène
[Musique]
mais qui donne à ce chef-d'oeuvre
bonjour madame vous avez une carte parce
qu'elle a un problème c'est que je crois
qu'il à ma place j'écoute le conte
normalement maintenant l'autre le jeu
pas combien s'appelle reviens ils
veulent ma gomme propose logiquement
comme une voile un truc moi je pense aux
codes couleurs maintenant les profs quoi
une rigueur des cousins jawad le coach
tout et n'importe quoi au roman je lui
ai fait ma voix les magouilles avril le
matin qu'on me dire waouh
quand tu peux jamais rien tu as tu fait
notre petit et élève modèle pour moi je
mets tissés pendant mes limites je pense
pas de l histoire c'est moi la victime
s'est pas l'autre aurait mal du tout ni
au temps d'algérie a fait une croix
dessus s'énervait me dire c'est pas
normal comme ça c'est pas normal
j'en ai marre - comme ballet comme ça tu
à fizi sur alors sans stop leurs noms
mais on s'occupe de tout
d'accord on reproche